five women nominated for Best Supporting
Actress this year developed remarkably
rounded and convincing characters a
murderous fugitive with a price on her
head
a young woman drawn into a forbidden
relationship in the 1950s an intrepid
reporter searching for truth an artist
whose spouse undergoes pioneering gender
confirmation surgery and the
plain-spoken marketing chief who goes
toe to toe with Steve Jobs here are the
nominees for performance by an actress
in a supporting role Jennifer Jason
Leigh the hateful eight carolyn rachel
mcadams spotlight alicia vikander the
Danish girl
Kate Winslet Steve Jobs
and the Oscar goes to Alicia vikander
the Danish
the first Oscar and nomination for
Alicia vikander
Wow thank you so much the Academy for
this incredible recognition I share this
with our fabulous crew and cast and I
want to thank I want to thank Gayle and
Ann and Nina and working title and focus
and Tom where are you my director thank
you so much for your support and belief
in me and Eddie there you are thank you
for being the best acting partner I
couldn't have done it without you you
erased my game I wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for my dream team which is Teresa
hang Hera chance Laura I want to tank
thank my friends Ilana that hammer and
my mom and dad thank you for giving me
the belief that anything can happen even
though I would never have believed this